when my favorite parts about the film is
the mother-daughter relationship there's
no I was laughing moments I was getting
emotional was that one of the reasons
that you were really attracted to this
project into the script definitely I
mean for sure I mean I'm a mother of
four and I'm also amazed that's still in
what year Ruby in 2019 that we still win
and there's a kind of a mother at the
center of film we talk about mothers
having to be a certain way and
Bernadette is certainly doesn't fit into
any traditional you know cinematic
mother role and so I love that and I
love Maria's writing and the level of
honesty and her satirical look at
motherhood and marriage and your
relationship to your career as a woman
and so all of that stuff drew me in and
then on top of which Rick was going to
direct it so bit of a no-brainer around
how do you describe somebody like
Bernadette Bernadette I guess she would
be described as a misanthrope except
except that she vibrates at a higher
level I think she's kind of um she's
sometimes manic and sometimes depressive
but she's very lost and and you know
she's experienced a deep professional
failure she's about to lose her daughter
to boarding school the one that she gave
it everything for so she's at a huge
turning point in her life and in she has
to get lost to be found in a way do you
think there's something that we can
learn from someone like Bernadette I
don't know I didn't think about
characters or films as being sort of
educational mediums but I definitely
think it speaks to a lot of things that
women are starting to talk about more
openly now is that you know what I
really haven't gone together I'm acting
like I have but I'm really haven't and
so we can talk more openly about our
problems and our failures and and you
see the wonderful thing about the film
is that you can see behind the dark
glasses of Bernadette you can see behind
what the mothers see at the school and I
think that there's a kind of a level of
almost raw exposing honesty that Maria
has as a writer and that
rick has definitely been interested in
exploring as a filmmaker well I have to
talk about the sunglasses they're
amazing they were Maria's yeah no I went
to weed spoken quite a lot we emailed
one another as you do you know it's very
easy to go Bernadette to have an email
exchange of the right yeah and then we'd
spoken on the phone and I really hadn't
been to Seattle before and I really
wanted to go and spend some time with
Maria and so she took me around and
showed me apart from Amazon redirecting
the entire city where she used to go in
the school route and took me to all the
various places and then at the end of
the weekend we spent she's she gave me
her dark glasses and I I thought well
these are the glasses I'm wearing in the
movie and I was so touched by that
because that was what she hid behind
when she first got to see out on the
rain and so do you have kind of that you
know as an actress I'll be seeing
different ways of getting into
characters but just that when you wear
the glasses is that something that you
just like like that kind of getting into
character you have a whole other process
well I guess it's it's also it's you
never know how if it's gonna happen or
when it's gonna happen but dad that was
definitely part of it and then it was
also okay so when when of the moments
when she takes them off like who is she
without them you know and you know there
was such wonderful actors to work
opposite and I know I wore the most when
I was with Christian weeks character
Audrey but yeah with the glasses were
definitely part of it I'll ask a
question where did you disappear to
anywhere in the world if you could well
look I it still is the Antarctic I've
had a very long romantic relationship
and of course I wanted to work on
reassembles writing with Richard
Linklater but I also really wanted to go
to the Antarctic so when Rick said you
know what it might have to be green
screen I was like and we did go green so
I did see the iceberg saw some whales a
bit of a life changing experience but I
don't yeah I think I'd probably go to
the actual Antarctic I still want to go